well well well if it isn't black Shelton
block okay how are you doing I'm doing
good we're ganging up on you especially
Kelly no you do did you dig it black
I got lucky miss the see I got caught
twice that's because you get on it all
of our nerves so bad that's like it's
like oh my god I'm gonna block her I'm
gonna strike the strike get the talent
right that's why we all blocked you
you did all blocked me except for what
you do ganging up on me I'm sorry
wait did everyone block me Glenn blocked
me okay yeah that was messed up how did
you feel about that I know dinner Fred
no soup for you Gwen you know it's it's
not the first time she's blocked me
that's that's it what does it feel like
to have more girl power this season it's
pretty great you guys would like a
little gang on the stage left no I love
it to me we knew each other before the
show but like we'd never work together
and I mean here's the thing like I can
get past the fact that like she's like
one of my heroes from trying good like I
mean it's really cool like she's kind of
really down to earth so that but it but
every once in a while I'm just like
sitting there and we're like arguing
over an artist like who's not really
arguing like pillow fighting over an
artist and I'm just like wow it's Gwen
Stefani
it's so cool like it's I love the four
of us it's weird not having Adam but it
is interesting the dynamic weird
literally all four different genres like
yeah and it's kind of interesting the
dynamic of that on the show I thought
was really fresh we got to see the first
episode as like a press preview and I
thought it was very very fresh that
makes one of us have you seen the first
episode no Bethenny never seen it's
great you guys are great really yeah
your million
yeah it's may have a lot of behind the
scenes like it you feel it's a little
gritty this year I like it yeah it's
good okay all the other coaches are
trying to lure away the country singers
from you all you've got is the country
why are they doing that it's not fair no
he just that's all we've got he's got a
huge eclectic team and ego and
so combine all of that I see us a win
number 7 7 John and he was like I'm the
nearest like you've never he's the
newest winner you know he's trying to
use his winning this over you winning
this yeah you know I don't really give a
crap what John says or does I'm here to
beat him I'm here to beat her and I'm
even here to beat Gwyn not easy that's
what I'm here to do well I guess my
question is what did you think of her
strategy Gwen was using the strategy
like we'll listen if you pick me you
technically kind of get Blake too right
that's bullcrap
because I'm not gonna help her you know
look you're messing up this interview
I'm opposed to say certain things and
now you're making me be Kelly Kelly's
learned in Spanish right now and because
of that I feel like she's also just
enough on her English let's say well now
she's a talk show a very successful talk
show congratulations on that a week in
that first week we can tell show one
you're living people love you I want to
know are you gonna use that to help you
like hey come be on my team you can then
start my talk show don't do that I would
honestly help any of the artists on any
team just because I've been where those
artists coming from a show so no I they
won't have like an upper hand
necessarily being on my team I would I
would let any of them like trying to get
through that door like even if it was
someone on his team great but if someone
on your team wins and then you celebrate
by doing this thing down the stairs on
your talk show I know well I have some
ideas for that coming up yeah it's very
exciting how are you doing all this I
know you shoot the talk show on the same
lot yeah so you're just running changing
clothes like no we've done it to where
I'm shooting a couple shows a day with
the talk show so and honestly at first I
was like and then now as we've done like
you know I think like around 20 like I'm
I'm doing like great at it now it's like
kind of like I'm one of those people
that likes a challenge and likes to be
productive and I like being busy all day
but I will say by the end of the day I
am in bed with my toddlers like this
you're on like 20 hours a day now it's
yeah but I
I like that like even when I retire one
day I'll probably go to college and to
get a degree in horticulture looks
something like I like I like being busy
she's learning Spanish talk about Taylor
mega mentor Taylor Swift and you knew
Taylor when she was a little bit bit so
now she's coming on as the mega mentor a
lot of people don't realize that I
raised
Taylor Swift and in the country music
worlds and she is she knows it in and
she did great though as a as a mentor
and she did the first time and then
coming back in the second time it's like
she's she's made for that you know and
and she's super smart and she's really
good at looking in looking at somebody's
performance and listening to them and
being able to go I know I know a couple
of things here that instantly that I
think we can tweak on and it'll take it
to the next level she's really good at
that I love that did you ask her to like
borrow any very sparkly outfits or
anything because I think she has on my
left gam yeah my left leg actually thank
you she's as bad as tall as me yeah I
think she's really tall yeah you know
sparkly bomber jacket on you bike would
be cute if I could lose a hundred and
eighty pounds I might be able to
actually shot that you're gonna love if
you want to see Blake in a really
awesome sparkly cheese
look oh my god I do remember that man
and that wasn't even very long ago
almost forgot we pulled up and you were
in this magical number it was good
you're gonna see it okay oh I'm so
excited a costume change for Blake fine
I gotta know if you could add a lyric
what would it be
from what Kelly has seven jobs they're
gonna win this time that's too many
syllables yeah Kelly's winning this time
yeah I hope you hear that in your head
we're going to sleep tonight
[Music]